stillbirth is a sad reality for many
families
there is a new resource to prevent
another heartache for expecting parents
bianca holman explains books
and influencers i wanted to know it all
to to make sure i have a good pregnancy
and it is overwhelming whether you are a
new or experienced
parent the pregnancy journey while
thrilling can cause anyone to worry
even with proper prenatal care and
routine visits some families are still
hit by devastating news
a stillbirth a stillbirth is a death or
a loss of a baby at or after 20 weeks of
pregnancy
or during delivery this affects about 1
in 160 births
that's according to the cdc the cord
could wrap around the baby's neck
there are lots of different things that
could happen you can lose the amniotic
fluid
and when these things happen the baby
slows down happy birthday a non-profit
is helping to educate expecting parents
about the importance of tracking a
baby's movement
especially during the third trimester of
pregnancy the campaign in the silver
state was made possible through a
partnership with the health plan of
nevada
the count the kids campaign is an app
for mothers to monitor their bundle of
joy
to know what's normal and note any
changes mother of two
marion falvey says she used the program
during both of her pregnancies
i would you know keep track of my babies
you know how he is alive how he's doing
and staying active
um because we had a little scare at the
time
where like he had arrhythmia if it took
you
10 minutes to get 10 kicks and then all
of a sudden it takes you
an hour or an hour and a half to get
those same 10 kicks
then you want to be aware of that so
instead of tracking on a piece of paper
the app makes it easy and convenient
access at your fingertips
and if there's a sudden change in either
direction you can tell your doctor
immediately trust your mom gut because
in the end
it's it's right if you can catch
a problem at that point you can save
your baby's life bianca holman 8 news
now
the user-friendly app is available in
the ios and google play stores